près de 800 personnes faisaient la file
à berlin pour voir en première mondiale
le film la déesse des mots cheveux
d'anaïs barbeau-lavalette je me sens
très fébrile très énervé je suis
tellement fier en même temps je le
ressens mon ventre c'est pire que des
papillons je vais j'adore
la déesse des mouches à feu et
l'histoire de catherine 16 ans qui vit
des moments difficiles lorsque ses
parents se séparent
elle se réfugie dans le monde de la
drogue c'est le goût d'être proche des
ltte le bout des doigts de traverser
avec ce passage adolescents brutale donc
c'est sûr que j'avais envie d'un film et
de façon assez intime
cette histoire qui se déroule dans les
années 90 et celle de geneviève
pieterson l'autrice du roman qui a
inspiré ce film
cette projection en première mondiale à
berlin est symbolique pour elle c'est
plus que symbolique
le rêve du personnage dans mon livre
c'est d'aller à berlin
aujourd'hui je réalise mon rêve le rêve
du personnage on étend ainsi donc c'est
non seulement qui se réalise pour vrai
vraiment présenté en compétition dans la
catégorie génération la déesse des
mouches à feu brille par sa vérité sa
sincérité
qu'est ce qui t'arrive et c'est qui il
dérange
il est frontale il s'adresse à un public
averti
la cinématographie et superbe berlais a
été l'occasion pour certains de ces
acteurs de voir le film pour la première
fois le le voir pour la première fois je
pense assez cnmr feeling surtout à
berlin dans une ville aussi festive cet
accueil enthousiaste de la grande
première mais un peu de baume sur une
vieille play de loterie ce du livre
j'aime rappeler toute ma vie de mon
directeur d'école j'étais dans une école
privée il m'avait assez à son bureau
puis m'avait dit ça ne fera rien de ta
vie continue comme ça j'espère qu'ils
nous écoutent aujourd'hui après la
berlinale l'as des as et les mouches à
feu sera présenté dans plusieurs autres
festivals le film pourrait être projeté
au québec à l'automne 2000 vrai ici
louis fait depuis mai radio-canada
berlin